are orcs at any time cannibals  yes oh yes they would eat they would eat  any kind of meat um that's why like in  the in the books when mary and pittman  are captured right and being carried  across by the orcs of course as you will  remember very well um  one of the scenes in the evening when  they when the orcs one of the few times  the orcs stop in camp they throw to  marion pippin uh meat and bread like  dried meat and bread and merry and  pippin won't even touch the meat yeah  because uh  tolkien's uh tolkien's phrase is the  meat of they dared not guess what  creature  um it's pretty clear that orcs will eat  any  meat of any kind so even so  i would i i cannot imagine them not  doing that we're not i don't remember  any specific references to it in  tolkien's works but i can see no reason  to think they would not  harmonize with me and hold me tight all  through the night you're shining bright  i'm your voice the baby you're my  [Music]